hallo mein name ist luca und wir beiden
süßen spielen heute zusammen war es
richtig nano kleiner balu in genau dem
süßen kleinen knochen hast du bekommen
das wundervolle freust dich richtig du
ein braves kamen die kranken theorien an
die die beiden in verbindung zueinander
stehen da stand einerseits jo der hände
ist ein automat tricks gekommen und balu
sitzt jetzt hier weil er den macher des
videos also mich schlagen will
nur so einen scheiß was kommt ja schon
wieder an ihre kleine pizza ich gebe dem
man einfach noch ein bisschen wasser
hier kannst du wissen was trinkt trinkt
jetzt hallo
ich habe da nicht wasser gekauft damit
du da einfach hinten schild in der
heutigen folge wollte ich mal schauen ob
wir irgendwie zu einem wettbewerb gehen
können und zwar gibt es ja einkaufen
spazieren wettkämpfe und da können wir
ja mal einfach ja was denn da ich denke
bei jedem tennisspieler was damals so
dass man gehorsamkeit es nie hingekriegt
deswegen dem display gewerben du kannst
die welt wenn wir nicht radikal
discussed dann kaufen bei dem eine
kleine süße display ist das süß wir
können schleifchen kaufen kommt weil
luca kaufmann dennoch mahnt eine rote
schleife oder kann ich im jetzt
ich glaube jetzt muss ich wohl oder übel
für dich also eine kleine rote schleife
kaufen in der nächsten folge bei mir
dann auch eine rote schriftführer dann
nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal die rote
sitzt und versuchen so ein bisschen die
blume der tisch lag das war jetzt nicht
so geplant und fang die disc super und
ob wir sind ein super team ich schaue
einfach mal ob das jetzt irgendwie
möglich ist an diesem wettbewerb
teilzunehmen
dabei soll am display bewerb teilnehmen
hallo und willkommen zur o mein gott
sieht schrecklich aus der kampf um den
sieg nähert sich dem finale die action
wird kommentiert von trans world
begleitet von einem fachkundigen freund
archiv mit zehn punkten liegt schäfer
und lucios von david in führung auf gott
wir müssen zehn punkte hinkriegen können
wir schaffen das schaffen
ja wir können das schaffen das ziel ist
es mindestens sechs punkte zu erreichen
müssten wir doch hinkriegen oder wir
grüßen wie den chip im ball
der name des trainers lautet bíobío wo
kann ich den ändern kann sie gefunden
ein punkt okay 30 zurückbringen
zurückgekehrt war und jetzt klappt so
und jetzt fand hongkong und ob du
dummkopf fahne so wallufer
es ist an der zeit die gewinner bekannt
zu geben sondern schauen wir weiter
dritter mit sechs punkten spiegel
wandelt von lexi den zweiten platz
belegt und ab juli war der sieg des zsc
emma bunton shiba inu von bern in den
wettbewerb mit einem ergebnis von 1
punkt mannschaft es somit nicht aufs
podest
du bist vom wettbewerb zurückgekehrt
sonst kommt doch auch immer dass die
dann jetzt irgendwie total fertig sind
oder sogar hungrig und durstig und so
einen scheiß okay das alles normal
wir schauen mal ich wollte denen ja
waschen in dieser folge ist dass ich
kann mir richtig durch
und liegt im total waschen und jetzt
wieder sauber machen und das war immer
das coolste mann die maschine konnte die
noch schön den filter reinigen dann hier
vorne hat er noch ein bisschen war
glänzte jetzt komplett jemand sieht
jetzt wunderschön aus kleiner see für
alu fühlt sich nun sehr gut dann machen
wir doch jetzt mal zum abschluss noch so
eine kleine draußen geht wieso habe ich
ihn gewaschen bevor wir einen gast tor
machen weil es einfach so mega der star
mit seiner pinken hals dann mit seinem
roten schleifchen
das ist doch eh bald wieder was gefunden
und zwar einen alonso hat einen gut
gemeinten ratschläge was hat denn der
alonso zu sagen wenn du deinen hund
vernachlässig finde dich nicht mehr
mögen verbringen viel zeit mit ihm
ich verbringe viel zeit mit balu point
euch an freunde macht hundebabys oder
guckt eine serie zusammen oder kocht
doch mal oder geht zusammen ins kino
danach wieder seine typische pro attacke
hier gab auch wiedersehen sondern über
lu ist immer noch neugierig aufs party
um vielleicht hat der kleine baby und
jetzt gerade einen freund gefunden kommt
mal wieder so ein bisschen durch hier
ein bisschen hüpfen hier auch wenn unter
eingekauft hätte es nicht endlich
umgebaut
dieser und dessen reinstes chaos kommen
doch kommen ihr seid vom spaziergang
zurückgekehrt er war ziemlich
anstrengend dann schauen wir mal eben
auf der ball hier noch irgendwas
benötigt normal normal butter
trockenfutter haben wir uns damit würde
ich sagen was das von dieser folge den
fanblock von dem kleinen galerie auf
meiner schulter und von dem ball der
sich hier schon wieder so mega krass
freuen wenn euch das video gefallen hat
würden wir uns alle drei oder zwei oder
wie ball oder ich und wir alle würden
uns über eine bewertung freuen und weil
dort die letzten worte für heute